cela fait 100 jours que joe biden a
succédé à donald trump à la maison
blanche
et durant ses 100 premiers jours il a eu
à s'exprimer sur la russie à de
nombreuses reprises voyons voir durant
les tout premiers jours de son mandat
joe biden ratifie avec vladimir poutine
la prolongation du traité new start sur
la réduction des armements nucléaires
un soulagement en soi alors que donald
trump ne paraissait pas disposé à
renouveler ce texte dans sa formulation
originale mais quasiment dans le même
temps joe biden donne également son avis
sur la sphère navalni se réservant ainsi
le droit d'évoquer tous les sujets quels
qu'ils soient je trouve que nous pouvons
à la fois agir dans l'intérêt mutuel de
nos pays dans le cadre de l'accord new
star et faire comprendre à la russie que
nous sommes très préoccupés par leur
comportement
qu'il s'agisse de navalni de solarwinds
ou de rapports sur les primes pour des
meurtres d'américains en afghanistan
le 17 mars joe biden met les pieds dans
le plat à la question en direct d'un
journaliste lui demandant s'il pensait
que le président russe était un tueur il
répond d'un fort peu diplomatique
oui vous connaissez vladimir poutine
vous pensez qu'il est un joueur je le
pense
alors quel prix doit-il payer le prix il
doit payer et vous allez le voir bientôt
brusque montée de fièvre entre les deux
présidents s'ensuit une réponse du
principal intéressé qui lui propose même
de poursuivre la conversation lors d'un
débat en ligne en direct
une proposition restée lettre morte
je me souviens que dans notre enfance
lorsqu'on se disputait dans la cour on
disait c'est celui qui lui en fait il
est et ce n'est pas par hasard ce n'est
pas simplement une expression utilisée
par les enfants ou une blague le sens
psychologique est très profond nous
voyons toujours dans autrui les qualités
qui nous sont propres mais je voudrais
inviter le président byden à poursuivre
nos échanges
mais à la condition suivante que nous le
fassions pratiquement en direct en ligne
fictive mais sans aucun délai et à
travers une discussion de liberté direct
il me semble oui à la serait intéressant
pour les peuples de russie et les
etats-unis ainsi que pour deux autres p1
par la suite joe biden et plusieurs
responsables de son administration
continue de s'exprimer sur la ferme à
valley de quoi irriter moscou qui
considère cette affaire comme interne au
pays et puis il y à l'ukraine en effet
depuis le début de l'année les tensions
sont montées d'un cran dans le donbass
le 46e président américain lui offre un
soutien plein et entier à kiev
alors que le conflit dans l'est du pays
entre dans sa septième année
le président byden a affirmé le soutien
indéfectible des états unis à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine face à
l'agression continue de la russie dans
le donbass et en crimée un soutien qui
se manifeste entre autres sous la forme
d'une aide militaire avec notamment la
livraison de deux navires patrouilleurs
et puis à la mi-avril en 24 heures
joe biden souffle le chaud et le froid
avec la russie dans un premier temps il
propose une rencontre à vladimir poutine
dans un pays tiers afin de normaliser
les relations entre les deux pays
signal positif mais quelques heures plus
tard seulement l'administration
américaine annonce qu'elle impose des
sanctions contre la russie sur la base
d'accusations d'ingérences ainsi que le
renvoi de diplomates
de quoi de nouveau douché tout espoir de
début de retour à des relations normales
j'ai été clair avec le président poutine
nous aurions pu aller plus loin mais
j'ai choisi de ne pas le faire j'ai
choisi d'adopter une réponse
proportionnée
les états unis ne cherchons pas à lancer
un cycle d'escaladé de conflit avec la
russie
nous voulons une relation stable et
prévisible si la russie continuent
d'interférer dans notre démocratie je
suis prêt à prendre d'autres mesures
pour y répondre
et pour la russie la situation dans
laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui est
principalement due aux mesures aux
décisions des amériques
sinon ce sera leur choix sinon on vivra
dans des conditions encore pire qu'à
l'époque de la guerre froide
je crois que pendant la guerre froide
les tensions étaient bien sûr très
sérieuse situation de crise des
situations à haut risque se sont
produites là de nombreuses reprises mais
il y avait un respect mutuel qui à mon
avis fait défaut aujourd'hui
enfin en toile de fond depuis le début
de son mandat même bien avant impossible
de ne pas mentionner le projet de
gazoduc nord stream 2 entre la russie et
l'allemagne auquel le président
américain est farouchement opposée pour
des raisons stratégiques mais aussi
économique résume le président maiden a
été très clair lorsqu'il a dit que ce
projet de gazoduc mauvaise idée pour
l'europe et pour les aider
ni à l'occasion de son discours au
congrès pour marquer les 100 premiers
jours de son mandat
joe by dell estime avoir été juste et
mesurée quant à la russie
je sais que ce sujet préoccupe certains
d'entre vous j'ai clairement fait savoir
à poutine que nous ne cherchons aucune
escale à nice mais aussi que leurs actes
auraient des conséquences s'il s'avère
qu'ils se sont effectivement produit
j'ai donné une réponse directe et
proportionnée à l'ingérence russe dans
nos élections ainsi qu aux cyber
attaques contre notre gouvernement et
nos entreprises dans les faits ce
premier bilan en terme de relations
entre la russie et les etats unis est
loin d'être réjouissant une attitude
défiante de nouvelles sanctions une
valse de diplomates sans oublier qu'à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a plus d'
ambassadeur russe à washington ni
l'ambassadeur américain à moscou
il reste malgré tout cette lueur
d'espoir la perspective d'une rencontre
entre les deux présidents
cet été mais difficile de croire qu'une
simple rencontre en face à face
rétablira d'un coup de baguette magique
des relations normalisées entre les deux
pays